this is lucy james on behalf of reviewer
alessandra barbosa
battle royals have only been around for
a handful of years
and for the most part they've strictly
stuck within the same genre of games
whether you're playing warzone fortnite
or apex legends you're always shooting a
gun and running from an
encroaching circle four guys ultimate
knockout an extremely
colorful and whimsical battle royale is
a great example of the genre growing
outside of its roots
it's a far more approachable take on the
multiplayer format
with simple controls and a variety of
mini games giving this competitive game
show
as much charm as they do tension
playing as one of 60 multi-colored jelly
bean-shaped contestants
you compete in a joyous and comical race
to be crowned the winner of each of four
guys 15-minute games
each one is broken up by various
mini-games with handfuls of players
eliminated after each one
these games all take on a variety of
themes from straightforward obstacle
race courses to frantic team games where
you're hoarding as many eggs as you can
into a basket each one makes good use of
full guy's easy to understand control
scheme
which lets you jump dive and grab with
ease
the pick up and play nature of full guys
is one of its strongest
aspects along with its quick and
entertaining games
it's never unclear when you need to jump
over a gap or navigate through the
hordes of contestants trying to reach
the finish line before you
its approachability lets anyone have
some fun with it while its stages bring
out glimmers of strategy for seasoned
players to take advantage of
with two dozen types of stages in
rotation four guys features a lot of
variety to each of its matches
although you'll encounter a race to kick
off each game each one is presented with
different obstacles and
elements that make them feel distinct
from each other the whirligig for
example is one of the longest you'll
encounter
featuring spinning fans and numerous
platforms with rotating hazards
ready to knock you off course by
contrast doordash is a much shorter race
filled with rows of closed doors with a
random few opening once players have
dived through them
the hunt for single routes through each
stage of doors create hilarious
bottlenecks through doorways not
equipped with the stress
sending players tumbling to the floor as
the group attempts to stampede to the
end
it's ridiculous but equally hilarious
every time
other survival based modes are equally
frantic and stressful
rollout for example puts all players on
a string of rotating platforms with
random walls
obstacles and gaps thrown in as they
spin around
moving between each platform while
avoiding the hordes of other players
trying to do the same is as
comical as it is strategic these
survival modes don't require the most
dexterous platforming generally ending
well before things speed up to an
uncomfortable
pace but the way they force all players
to get uncomfortably close to one
another and
so random chaos is extremely effective
if you've ever watched wipeout or
takeshi's castle you'll recognize the
slapstick nature to each stage and
appreciate the care given to balance
elements of luck and skill
with only a handful missing this mark
tail tag gives some players tails and
tasks everyone else with hunting them
down and yanking it off for themselves
it's a fun game of tag on paper but with
each player moving the same speed and
the distance required to latch on and
steal a tail being so small
it quickly becomes a frustrating
runaround it's even worse when used as
the match type for the final stage where
the only player at the end with a tail
wins the whole thing this stage is too
large for the handful of players left in
the game giving an unfair advantage to
the one that happens to start with the
tail
not all of the finales in fall guys
faces these issues however with two
standing out
hexagon is a nerve-wracking platforming
test where the ground disappears beneath
you as you run over it
it's a game where you're rewarded for
staying on each level of platforms for
as long as possible either by making
smart jumps across gaps made by
other players or navigating
intelligently around each level
to stay above the pit of slime below
similarly jump showdown puts all players
on a single platform with two spinning
beams
they move at different speeds forcing
you to continue moving and time your
jumps so that you aren't caught out when
both beams line up
both modes involve a level of skill that
make them more suitable for determining
the overall winner of each game
you'll frequently be thrown into
team-based modes too which can either
delight or dishearten based on who
you're paired up with
a race to get a giant ball through an
obstacle course can become a test of
patience when just one or two teammates
aren't pulling
their weight while rocket league-styled
games of oversized football can feel
extremely one-sided for the same reasons
these aren't faults of the game modes
themselves
most capture the same goofy fun of the
solo ones but when your entire team is
eliminated thanks to just one
or two players it does take some of the
excitement out of immediately jumping
into another game
with its short games and easy to grasp
mechanics four guys is easily the most
approachable and welcoming battle royale
yet
its bursting color and varied game modes
do a good job of reeling you in and
keeping you hooked even if a handful
feel at odds with the easy going nature
of its premise
it can be disheartening to have a game
end prematurely due to uneven team
matches and worse still when you're
forced into one of four guys
unsatisfying finale modes but neither
are enough to derail the fun fall guys
consistently generates
with its chaotic obstacle courses and
ear worm soundtrack ensuring you'll be
coming back
for more
[Music]